today i want to tell you three stories
from my life
that's it no big deal
just three stories
the first story is about connecting the
dots
i dropped out of reed college after the
first six months but then stayed around
as a drop in for another 18 months or so
before i really quit so why'd i drop out
it started before i was born
my biological mother was a young unwed
graduate student and she decided to put
me up for adoption
she felt very strongly that i should be
adopted by college graduates so
everything was all set for me to be
adopted at birth by a lawyer and his
wife except that when i popped out they
decided at the last minute that they
really wanted a girl
so my parents who were on a waiting list
got a call in the middle of the night
asking
we've got an unexpected baby boy do you
want him they said of course my
biological mother found out later that
my mother had never graduated from
college and that my father had never
graduated from high school
she refused to sign the final adoption
papers she only relented a few months
later when my parents promised that i
would go to college this was the start
in my life
and 17 years later i did go to college
but i naively chose a college that was
almost as expensive as stanford and all
of my working-class parents savings were
being spent on my college tuition after
six months i couldn't see the value in
it
i had no idea what i wanted to do with
my life and no idea how college was
going to help me figure it out
and here i was spending all the money my
parents had saved their entire life so i
decided to drop out and trust that it
would all work out okay
it was pretty scary at the time but
looking back it was one of the best
decisions i ever made the minute i
dropped out i could stop taking the
required classes that didn't interest me
and begin dropping in on the ones that
looked far more interesting it wasn't
all romantic
i didn't have a dorm room so i slept on
the floor in friends rooms i returned
coke bottles for the five cent deposits
to buy food with
and i would walk the seven miles across
town every sunday night to get one good
meal a week at the hari krishna temple i
loved it
and much of what i stumbled into by
following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be priceless later on let
me give you one example
reed college at that time offered
perhaps the best calligraphy instruction
in the country throughout the campus
every poster every label on every drawer
was beautifully hand calligraphed
because i had dropped out and didn't
have to take the normal classes i
decided to take a calligraphy class to
learn how to do this i learned about
serif and sans serif typefaces about
varying the amount of space between
different letter combinations about what
makes great typography great it was
beautiful historical artistically subtle
in a way that science can't capture and
i found it fascinating none of this had
even a hope of any practical application
in my life
but 10 years later when we were
designing the first macintosh computer
it all came back to me
and we designed it all into the mac it
was the first computer with beautiful
typography if i had never dropped in on
that single course in college the mac
would have never had multiple typefaces
or proportionally spaced fonts and since
windows just copied the mac it's likely
that no personal computer would have
them if i had never dropped out i would
have never dropped in on that
calligraphy class and personal computers
might not have the wonderful typography
that they do
of course it was impossible to connect
the dots looking forward when i was in
college but it was very very clear
looking backwards ten years later again
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards
so you have to trust that the dots will
somehow connect in your future you have
to trust in something your gut destiny
life karma whatever because believing
that the dots will connect down the road
will give you the confidence to follow
your heart
even when it leads you off the well-worn
path and that will make all the
difference
my second story is about love and loss i
was lucky i found what i loved to do
early in life
woz and i started apple in my parents
garage when i was 20.
we worked hard and in 10 years apple had
grown from just the two of us in a
garage into a two billion dollar company
with over four thousand employees
we just released our finest creation the
macintosh a year earlier and i just
turned 30 and then i got fired
how can you get fired from a company you
started
well
as apple grew we hired someone who i
thought was very talented to run the
company with me and for the first year
or so things went well but then our
visions of the future began to diverge
and eventually we had a falling out when
we did our board of directors sided with
him and so at 30 i was out
and very publicly out what had been the
focus of my entire adult life was gone
and it was devastating
i really didn't know what to do for a
few months
i felt that i'd let the previous
generation of entrepreneurs down that i
had dropped the baton as it was being
passed to me i met with david packard
and bob noyce and tried to apologize for
screwing up so badly i was a very public
failure and i even thought about running
away from the valley but something
slowly began to dawn on me i still loved
what i did the turn of events at apple
had not changed that one bit i'd been
rejected but i was still in love and so
i decided to start over i didn't see it
then
but it turned out that getting fired
from apple was the best thing that could
have ever happened to me the heaviness
of being successful was replaced by the
lightness of being a beginner again less
sure about everything
it freed me to enter one of the most
creative periods of my life during the
next five years i started a company
named next another company named pixar
and fell in love with an amazing woman
who would become my wife pixar went on
to create the world's first computer
animated feature film toy story and is
now the most successful animation studio
in the world in a remarkable turn of
events
apple bought next and i returned to
apple and the technology we developed it
next is at the heart of apple's current
renaissance
and laureen and i have a wonderful
family together i'm pretty sure none of
this would have happened if i hadn't
been fired from apple it was awful
tasting medicine but i guess the patient
needed it sometimes life's going to hit
you in the head with a brick don't lose
faith i'm convinced that the only thing
that kept me going was that i loved what
i did you've got to find what you love
and that is as true for work as it is
for your lovers your work is going to
fill a large part of your life and the
only way to be truly satisfied is to do
what you believe is great work and the
only way to do great work is to love
what you do if you haven't found it yet
keep looking and don't settle as with
all matters of the heart you'll know
when you find it and like any great
relationship it just gets better and
better as the years roll on so keep
looking
don't settle
my third story is about death
when i was 17 i read a quote that went
something like if you live each day as
if it was your last someday you'll most
certainly be right
it made an impression on me and since
then for the past 33 years i've looked
in the mirror every morning and asked
myself if today were the last day of my
life would i want to do what i am about
to do today
and whenever the answer has been no for
too many days in a row i know i need to
change something remembering that i'll
be dead soon is the most important tool
i've ever encountered to help me make
the big choices in life because almost
everything all external expectations all
pride all fear of embarrassment or
failure these things just fall away in
the face of death leaving only what is
truly important remembering that you are
going to die is the best way i know to
avoid the trap of thinking you have
something to lose you are already naked
there is no reason not to follow your
heart
about a year ago i was diagnosed with
cancer i had a scan at 7 30 in the
morning and it clearly showed a tumor on
my pancreas i didn't even know what a
pancreas was the doctors told me this
was almost certainly a type of cancer
that is incurable and that i should
expect to live no longer than three to
six months my doctor advised me to go
home and get my affairs in order which
is doctor's code for prepare to die it
means to try and tell your kids
everything you thought you'd have the
next 10 years to tell them in just a few
months it means to make sure everything
is buttoned up so that will be as easy
as possible for your family it means to
say your goodbyes i live with that
diagnosis all day later that evening i
had a biopsy where they stuck an
endoscope down my throat through my
stomach into my intestines put a needle
into my pancreas and got a few cells
from the tumor i was sedated but my wife
who was there told me that when they
viewed the cells under a microscope the
doctor started crying because it turned
out to be a very rare form of pancreatic
cancer that is curable with surgery
i had the surgery and thankfully i'm
fine now this was the closest i've been
to facing death and i hope it's the
closest i get for a few more decades
having lived through it i can now say
this to you with a bit more certainty
than when death was a useful but purely
intellectual concept no one wants to die
even people who want to go to heaven
don't want to die to get there and yet
death is the destination we all share no
one has ever escaped it and that is as
it should be because death is very
likely the single best invention of life
it's life's change agent it clears out
the old to make way for the new right
now the new is you but someday not too
long from now you will gradually become
the old and be cleared away
sorry to be so dramatic but it's quite
true your time is limited so don't waste
it living someone else's life don't be
trapped by dogma which is living with
the results of other people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drowned out your own inner voice and
most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition they
somehow already know what you truly want
to become everything else is secondary
when i was young
there was an amazing publication called
the whole earth catalog on the back
cover of their final issue was a
photograph of an early morning country
road beneath it were the words
stay hungry
stay foolish
it was their farewell message as they
signed off
stay hungry
stay foolish
and i have always wished that for myself
and now
i wish that for you
stay hungry stay foolish
[Music]
you